PRESIDENT’S REMOVAL OF
LIEUTENANT COLONEL ALEXANDER
PENMAN, HIS TWIN BROTHER AND
AMBASSADOR’S ONLINE FROM THE KEY
POST ADMINISTRATION.
YESTERDAY SHE CALLED FOR THE DNC
DNC’S HEAD, TOM PEREZ TO RESIGN.
SHE HAS LIFE IN NEW HAMPSHIRE,
HOW ARE YOU, GOOD TO SEE YOU AND
NICE TO SEE YOU.
FELLOW DEMOCRATS ARE AFRAID TO
COME ON THE SHOW.
>> I DON’T KNOW WHY.
YOU ARE A NICE GUY, SEAN.
>> Sean: WHY DID PEREZ RESIGN?
>> VOTERS IN THIS PRIMARY NEED
TO HAVE THE CONFIDENCE THAT
VOTES WILL BE TALENTED AND THE
VOICES WILL BE HEARD.
UNFORTUNATELY, HE’S HAD A
FAILURE OF LEADERSHIP AND BEING
ABLE TO UPHOLD THAT FAITH AND
THAT TRUST.
WE’VE GOT A LOT OF PRIMARIES
COME A LOT OF ELECTIONS BETWEEN
NOW AND THE CONVENTION.
WE NEED TO BE ABLE TO GET BACK
ON TRACK.
>> Sean: I COULD NEVER
UNDERSTAND THAT IT WAS OBVIOUS
THAT 2016 DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY WAS
RIGGED.
IT WAS RIGGED AGAINST
BERNIE SANDERS.
AND DONNA BRAZILE WHEN SHE TOOK
OVER FOR DEBBIE WATSON SCHOLZ,
CALLED HIM ONE DAY AND SAID,
YEAH, YOU KIND OF GOT CHEATED.
NOW THEY WANT TO CHANGE THE
RULES SO BLOOMBERG CAN GET ONTO
BASE AND THEY WANT TO CHANGE THE
RULES AND LET SUPERDELEGATES
VOTE FROM ACCOUNT ON THE FIRST
BALLOT AGAIN TO RIGGED THE
PRIMARY.
THAT IS YOUR PARTY, THAT IS NOT
MY PARTY.
>> THAT IS PART OF THE PROBLEM.
THIS WAS POST 2016 WHERE A LOT
OF PEOPLE THOUGHT THAT THE
PROBLEMS WITH THE SYSTEM, WHICH
IS THE SUPERDELEGATES AND HELP
HARD TO CAST THEIR VOTES AND GET
THEIR VOICES HEARD HAS
DRIVEN THE FRUSTRATION I’M
HEARING FROM DEMOCRATS WITH THIS
PROCESS TODAY.
YOU KNOW COMMITS NOT ONLY WHAT
HAPPENED IN IOWA.
IOWA VOTERS LOST OUT IN THAT
WHOLE SITUATION BUT ALSO THAT
DECISION THAT DECISION THAT ALL
OF A SUDDEN, THE RULES CHANGE TO
BENEFIT THIS BILLIONAIRE
MICHAEL BLOOMBERG.
AND THE DECISIONS AT THE DNC
MADE THROUGHOUT, UNFORTUNATELY,
TO HOLD A TREE PRIMARY BEFORE
THE VOTERS HAVE A CHANCE TO GO
OUT AND CAST THEIR VOTE.
THEIR BIGGER CHANGES THAT WE
NEED SUPERDELEGATES REMAIN A
CONCERN.
I’VE BEEN A BIG ADVOCATE FOR
GETTING RID OF SUPERDELEGATES
ALTOGETHER.
I GIVE DEMOCRATS THEY DON’T HAVE
SUPERDELEGATES AND THEY WILL
MAKE THEIR CHOICE.
>> Sean: I THINK YOU’VE BEEN
TREATED HORRIBLY.
THE THINGS YOU HAVE BEEN SAYING
ABOUT HILLARY CLINTON, I SUPPORT
YOU ONE.
I THOUGHT THAT WAS COURAGEOUS.
JUST ACKNOWLEDGING A SIMPLE
TRUTH THAT A PRESIDENT GETS TO
HIRE AND FIRE THE PEOPLE HE
WANTS, NOT PEOPLE THAT DISAGREE
WITH HIS POLICY.
>> ACTUALLY, THERE WAS A DEEPER
ISSUE THAT NOT MANY PEOPLE ARE
TALKING ABOUT, WHICH IS IT IS
NOT BASED ON OPINION.
THIS IS BASED ON THE
CONSTITUTION.
NOW, I’M A SOLDIER SERVING ARMY
NATIONAL GUARD.
>> Sean: THANK YOU FOR YOUR
SERVICE.
>> THANK YOU, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BUT AS A MEMBER OF
CONGRESS, I TOOK AN OATH TO THE
CONSTITUTION AS DOES EVERY
MEMBER OF CONGRESS.
AND IT IS THE CONSTITUTION THAT
PROVIDES THAT OUR FOREIGN POLICY
IS SET BY THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AS WELL AS
SIGNIFICANT WAYS BY CONGRESS,
NOT BY UNELECTED DEMOCRATS AND
NOT BY THE MILITARY.
AND THE REASON WHY OUR FOUNDERS
HAD THE WISDOM TO DO THIS, THEY
KNEW IF VOTERS WERE UNHAPPY WITH
THE FOREIGN POLICY DECISIONS
BEING MADE, THEY COULD MAKE THAT
DECISION AT THE BALLOT BOX TO
HIRE OR FIRE WHERE THEY CAN’T DO
THAT WITH UNELECTED BUREAUCRATS
OR OTHERS.
>> Sean: THIS IS WHAT MAKES
YOU VERY UNIQUE IN YOUR PARTY,
TO BE HONEST.
ONE, YOU HAVE BEEN COURAGEOUS
ENOUGH TO COME ON OTHER SHOWS.
GOSH, TO BE SEEN BY PEOPLE.
YOU GO ON THOSE FAKE NEWS
NETWORKS KNOW WHEN WE’LL SEE YOU
BUT ON A SERIOUS NOTE, THE
STICKS IN MY CRAW.
WE HEARD JOE BIDEN SAY YOU ARE
NOT GETTING $1 BILLION UNTIL YOU
FIRE THE UKRAINIAN PROSECUTOR
WHO WAS INVESTIGATING HIS SON,
WHO IS BEING PAID MILLIONS, WHO
IS ON TAPE SAYING THAT HE HAD NO
EXPERIENCE IN OIL, GAS, ENERGY
IN UKRAINE.
CONGRESSWOMAN, THAT SOUND GOOD
TO YOU?
>> I DON’T KNOW WHAT THOSE TAPE
SAID.
>> Sean: COME ON, COME ON.
>> JOE BIDEN WILL BE HELD TO THE
STANDARD --
>> Sean: HE IS NOT BEING HELD
TO THE STANDARD.
>> THIS IS MY WHOLE POINT, THE
VOTERS IN THIS COUNTRY AND THE
DEMOCRATIC PRIMARY, HERE IN
NEW HAMPSHIRE WITH INDEPENDENTS
AND LIBERTARIANS COMING OUT TO
CAST THEIR VOTE TOMORROW.
THEY WILL MAKE THEIR DECISIONS
BASED ON WHO THEY BELIEVE WILL
BEST SERVE.
>> Sean: IF YOU COULD CALL
DONALD TRUMP AND SAY COME EVEN
THOUGH WE DISAGREE ON SOME
THINGS COME I WANT TO WORK WITH
YOU ON X, WHAT WOULD IT BE?
>> THERE IS A LONG LIST.
THERE IS FAR MORE THAT WE NEED
TO DO ONE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
REFORM.
I WOULD LOVE TO BE ABLE TO WORK
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP ON AND
THINK THIS FAILED WAR ON DRUGS.
>> Sean: WILL HE LEGALIZE
DRUGS?
>> BY ENDING THE FEDERAL
MARIJUANA --
>> Sean: DO YOU WANT TO
LEGALIZE DRUGS?
>> ANSWER THE QUESTION.
>> WHERE THERE HAS BEEN A
DECRIMINALIZATION --
>> Sean: HEROIN?
>> SO THAT WE TREAT SUBSTANCE
ABUSE.
>> Sean: WOULD YOU LEGALIZE
HEROIN?
WOULD YOU LEGALIZE HEROIN?
DON’T MAKE ME BE A JERK.
>> AS A HEALTH CARE ISSUE RATHER
THAN PUTTING MORE AND MORE --
>> Sean: HEROIN?
WOULD YOU LEGALIZE IT?
>> THIS IS MY POINT WE HAVE TO
END THE WAR ON DRUGS.
WE CAN HELP PEOPLE WHO NEED